[Music]
let's talk about
money
when was the last time you told someone
how much you make
how much is in your bank account
how about how you invest your capital if
you invest at all
would you be willing to tell me
right now
my bet
probably not
because that's what society has taught
us isn't it
at the dinner table we don't discuss
religion
politics
or money
well
let me tell you why i wish we would
talk about money
flashback to freshman fall
i had just finished moving in and i'm
meeting the guys who live down the hall
nick and matt
and nick
kicks off the intros
now at first it actually seems like nick
and i have a lot in common
he's six feet tall
i'm
five ten and three quarters but it's
basically the same thing
he's in the sailing team and i mean i
don't want to brag but i was captain of
the jp volleyball team back in ninth
grade
but then he says his dad
works at a hedge fund
uh what's a hedge fund
matt chimes in and says that his dad
also works in finance he's a banker
oh well that one i know like a bank
teller that's cool so i ask him which
bank switch matt responds
goldman
huh
never heard of goldman must be some tiny
bank
personally i'm a wells fargo boy
then they ask
how about you kevin what do your folks
do
oh they're both waiters mom's been the
sheridan since before i was born
nick raises an eyebrow
whoa wait are you
on financial aid
yeah i lucked out and got a ton you guys
and without answering me nick and matt
exchange a look
change the topic
and move on
what just happened
why are they so surprised
is it weird that i'm on financial aid
should i be ashamed that my parents are
waiters
maybe i should say they work in
hospitality
or maybe i should avoid talking about
them all together
these unwelcome thoughts plagued me
during my time at harvard as i continued
to meet peers who were shocked almost
uncomfortable to hear by my background
making me feel like i didn't belong
so
to combat this growing insecurity
i decided to pursue the most lucrative
career path i could think of
investment banking
so
fast forward a few years i'm now 22
years old working on wall street making
more than my parents combined
and that's not a flex
it's the reality
i'm chatting with my buddy rob and he's
complaining about the bank's no trade
policy
but as someone who had only learned
about the stock market through econ
courses in college i ask
why do you care
do you even own stock
yeah of course my mom bought me some
apple shares when i was 10 and i started
trading back in high school don't you
uh no
but that's cool could you show me how to
get started sometime
i don't know about that man you should
just ask your financial advisor
who the heck has a financial advisor at
20
while i didn't even know how to open a
brokerage account
rob has been earning passive income
before he learned long division
what
so at this point i'm trying to feel
pretty frustrated i went to the same
college as rob i worked at the same firm
as rob i even had the same job as rob so
i thought the playing field was leveled
why was i still so behind
well
the reality was
as the son
of blue-collar immigrant parents who
didn't go to college
and as a product of boston's public
school system
i was financially illiterate
just like 90 percent of high school
graduates in this country
here's some stats
the average american makes around fifty
thousand dollars a year
nearly two thirds of americans live
paycheck to paycheck
and the majority of americans
can't afford a 500 emergency expense
think about that one
unexpected accident and they fall into
debt
but why does this matter
why should you care
well
it's because financial literacy is
directly linked
to wealth inequality
in the u.s the top 10 of households hold
70 percent of this country's wealth
while the bottom 50 percent
hold
two
this massive wealth divide is
unsustainable and it puts our society at
risk of instability
but to bring it down to a more personal
level
it also results in limited opportunity
and mobility for the disadvantaged
for people like my mother
who had the same job as a waitress her
entire working life
and put every penny she earned into a
low interest savings account because she
didn't know any
better had she developed financial
fluency sooner
she wouldn't have torn her shoulder from
carrying heavy platters for 30 years
straight
and today
she wouldn't be depending upon the
checks i sent her monthly as her main
source of income since she can no longer
work from her injuries
here at the gsb
one in ten students identify as first
generation low-income
meaning there are others in this room
whose family share similar stories
if we want a fair and equal society we
must reduce this inequality
and we need to recognize that we all can
help narrow this gap
so here's what i'd like to see more of
recently i was catching up with my
former boss
he's a cfo and has become a life mentor
and close friend
now as someone quickly approaching 30
i'm starting to think about financially
preparing for
the wedding
the house
children
also known as money parasites
so i really needed his advice
and when i told him my net worth
unprompted
he was taken aback
kevin are you usually this open with
your personal
finances yeah why not
huh okay
well i think you're off to a good start
but here are some things i'd start
thinking about
and he starts rattling on about
increasing my exposure to crypto 529
plans backdoor roth conversions
irrevocable trusts
let me just stop there who in this room
just heard complete gibberish
my point exactly
these are tools and strategies to
diversify and grow my wealth and now i
feel much better prepared to start the
next chapter of my life
but recognize that this only happened
because of two things
i was willing to be transparent
ask questions share my numbers
and i found someone who was willing to
share their knowledge
so here's my call to action for you
let's normalize talking about money
for those of you who feel like you
struggle with personal finances there's
no need to feel embarrassed your net
worth does not dictate your personal
worth as a human being
it takes a lot of courage to embrace
your financial situation but allow
yourself to be vulnerable and seek out
advice
now for those of you who are more
financially savvy
share your knowledge
while i appreciate the intent to be
modest that humility ends up being
harmful because it prevents the exchange
of valuable information
recognize that sharing your knowledge is
infinitely more helpful than not
and if we can all start doing this
we will take a massive step forward
in addressing the financial knowledge
gap we have in this country
and my hope
is that as a result we can tackle wealth
inequality from a grassroots perspective
and together build a more trusting
financially aware society
and in this world
maybe people like me
don't have to face the same insecurity i
did growing up
more importantly
maybe people like my mother will get the
opportunities that they deserve
all we have to do
is talk about
money
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]